herzlich konnte diese wieder leute
dieses video ist der erste teil von zwei
von meinem torten mit dave den ich mit
ihm hat er ist wie er sein auto gefahren
sind in diesem video habe ich mit dave
über geld geredet seine eltern geredet
und darüber geredet wie es war 50.000
euro ein paar tagen zu verdienen heute
viel spaß mit dem medium aber der gar
nicht immer direkt drauf kommen auf die
sache die du gerade eben meinte sie
haben schon mal ganz kurz angeschnitten
dass du richtig richtig viel geld mit
gamestop gemacht hast ja das ist ja
komplett geisteskrank also du bist 22
hasst man kann sich ja ausrechnen liste
52.000 auch für den wagen hier gezahlt -
9000 euro prämie
also kann man ja sagen ich will nicht
dass du den genauen betrag können aber
du hast mindestens 43.000 euro mit
gamestop spekulation gemacht für alle
ganz kurz noch mal die das nicht über
kommen mit gamestar und da ging es
einfach darum dass sehr viele leute sich
auf reddit zusammengeschlossen haben um
professionelle investoren auszuquetschen
das ging mit einer gewissen technik
geben die sehr schlau angewandt und du
hast ja mitgemacht genau wie ist das
vorweg wir haben uns nicht zusammen
geschlossen
es wurde sich nicht abgesprochen ja ja
und sie wurden immer wieder news jeder
hat nach wie vor für sich alleine
entschieden ja aber ich habe mich da ein
bisschen informiert und habe gedacht es
wäre für mich schlau damit zu ich hab
das ja auch verfolgt und leute für alle
die es noch nicht wussten ich habe bwl
studiert mit schwerpunkt finanzen und
auch meine bachelorarbeit über den
aktienmarkt geschrieben also ich war
sehr interessiert an dem phänomen und
habe selbst halt schiss gehabt da geld
rein zu investieren weil ich mir dachte
das geht gegen meine
investmentphilosophie ich bin sehr
konservativ da nur itf und ganz ganz
simpel aber du bist halt einfach
wirklich im best gemeinten sinne auch ab
und zu ein bisschen so ein holzkopf also
du weißt dass das nicht negativ meinen
du willst dann einfach so aber kommt
könnte bei der aktion sterben aber ich
finde es lustig dass machen ich habe ja
ja drei gemeinde und und und diese ok
ich muss nicht alles immer durchdenken
soll ich mache jetzt einfach mal das
heißt jetzt auch da angewandt eigentlich
genau also ich wie ich das gerne
beschreibe ohne jetzt auf den youtube
kanal ohne den youtube kanal zu meinen
damit ich mich selber ein bisschen als
grenzgänger
schreibe oder so oder so ja ja also es
macht mir spaß bei sachen all in zu
gehen das macht mir spaß sachen zu
machen die vielleicht gefährlich sind es
macht mir spaß sachen zu machen wo viele
leute denken das ist absolut dumm ist ja
nach wie vor ist es so dass ich probiere
das risiko immer ab gut abzuwägen okay
das lässt sich bei einer aktion die bei
gamestop aber natürlich nicht es lässt
sich nicht ab wegen das ist war ein
absolut risikofreudige riesen investment
und das will ich auch gar nicht
schönreden ich hatte glück es hat
funktioniert ich habe daran geglaubt und
das ist gut muss aber dazu sagen dass
das für mich vorerst eine einmalige
sache war gut und ich schon als ich am
anfang investiert habe mir gesagt habe
okay ich mache das einmal und
hoffentlich klappt und dann lasse ich
erst mal weiter die finger davon und
verfolgen eine ähnliche strategie wie du
mit verschiedenen dips und das finde ich
auch schlau weil meine meinung dazu ist
und ich glaube das würden auch viele
teil
das was du da gemacht das ist
glücksspiel also das war klar ich will
jetzt auch nicht zu sehr in die details
gehen
es war aber klar dass das irgendwann
kollabieren würde und auch nicht erst in
sechs monaten sondern früher und die
frage wahrheit nur bin ich da zwei tage
vor dem kollaps raus oder kaufe ich dann
erst und verliert 80 prozent von meinem
geld du hast was hat rechtzeitig das ist
auch ein faktor wie gut informiert man
sich mal so was die schnellsten drin
ja und man erst dann zu investieren wenn
die öffentlichen medien darüber sprechen
dann ist zu spät gekommen und so wenn du
über in der faz oder sogar welche
internet sachen ließ dann lass es da
genau würde ich da nicht so mitmachen
anknüpfend daran er wird schon
festgestellt was sehr sehr sehr viel
geld da verdienst wirklich unfassbar
viel geld mit seiner risikobereitschaft
was bedeutet eigentlich geld für dich
freiheit
okay das geld zu haben geld zu verdienen
ist weniger weniger cool weil ich gerne
viel geld haben will sondern weil jetzt
einfach in freiheit ermöglicht ich kann
ideen umsetzen die ich gerne umsetzen
möchte ich kann mich kopf mäßig auf
andere sachen fokussieren als darauf es
gab zeiten in denen ich als student
natürlich auch relativ wenig geld hatte
und geldsorgen zu haben ich hatte nie
geld geld sorgen dass ich dachte okay
ich kann die miete am ende des monats
nicht nicht bezahlen aber wenn etwas
weniger auf dem konto ist und man in
seiner in seiner bewegungsfreiheit im
alltag dadurch eingeschränkt ist dass
man nicht so leben kann wie man möchte
dann nimmt das wirklich stark die
gedanken ein und komplett
und ich will nicht wissen wie es für
leute ist die wirkliche geldnöte haben
deswegen ist es für mich einfach
freiheit und im morgens aufzustehen um
zu wissen was ich auch in drei monaten
noch meine miete zahlen kann ist gibt
mir einfach eine absolute ruhe und das
ist eigentlich das das größte für mich
das schon es schon segen auf jeden fall
ich muss daran denken leute an so eine
studie die habe ich mal in sowie sagt
mantek präsentiert gesehen irgendwie
hatte nicu studie mit indischen
reisbauern gemacht waren es glaube ich
weil die frage war quasi was ist
eigentlich das bedeutet das sind leute
die arm sind dumm weil das ist ja so
bissig die populäre meinung und diese
studie gesagt nein die haben nämlich
festgestellt die haben bei den gleichen
reisbauern vor und nach der ernte und
nach verkauf der ernte gutes gemacht und
haben feststellen können dass in
signifikanter unterschied dazwischen
zwischen den zwei zeitpunkt war und zwar
in dem moment wo die ernte noch nicht
verkauft und abgebaut war und die farmer
somit kein geld hatten haben sie in den
eco test schlechter abgeschnitten
ok und das heißt quasi das nicht
zwingend leute die arm sind irgendwie
keine ahnung dümmer sind als andere
schlechte entscheidung treffen und vor
allem also nicht nur sondern auch dass
man allein deswegen schlechter
entscheidung trifft weil man zum
beispiel wenig geld hatten sondern und
das ist finde ich ein krasser befund
und insofern kann ich das verstehen dass
du sagst es freiheit dazu jetzt mal
anknüpfen du bist ja auch nicht der typ
der also ich gehe zum beispiel leute
gerne mal so schickimicki feiern so
erhält oder so war es an partys
überhaupt die mädels bisschen
hochgestylten hochschule so finde ich
geil und ich bin auch manchmal anfällig
dafür dass ich denke ich muss viel geld
ausgeben um zu gelten
weißt du sooo dieses okay kommt mein
auto gucken gucken jetzt eine flasche im
club oder so das machst du nicht
naja die clubs hatten noch nicht offen
als ich ein bisschen du bist ja das ist
tatsächlich so also ich hatte noch nie
viel geld in einem club oder sonst was
aber es stimmt schon also ich bin
weniger der typ für solche sachen muss
aber sagen dass die dass die gedanken
superschnell angefangen haben sich um
luxus themen zugreifen als ich das erste
mal geld verdient habe ob einmal
interessiere ich mich für autos auf
einmal interessiere ich mich für uhren
ja der roten für die ich vorher nie was
übrig hatte themen die in keiner weise
wichtig für mich waren haben auf einmal
einen gewissen stellenwert bekommen und
trotz alledem glaube ich dass jetzt eher
weniger der typ für so super krasse
luxus sachen zu binden du bist ja heute
auch einfach echt krass geerdet durch
durch seine eltern als sie müsste dir
wirklich mal kennenlernen leute weiß ja
bewusst machen wirst also sehr sehr
eigentlich understatement pur denn der
eltern man wirklich an das statement pur
so muss man sagen ohne ohne darauf zu
achten ohne das zu machen weil man weil
man unbedingt wenig geld ausgeben will
sondern weil meine eltern über die zeit
einfach gemerkt haben dass es ihnen
nichts gibt wir haben sachen zu kaufen
haben sich was er aufgebaut und haben
sich dann so sinnlos gesagt über von den
konsum denke ich mal ja und das ist ein
gedankengang der ich in vielen momenten
sympathisch finde muss ich sagen weil
dieses konsumieren ich jagte das nächste
auto jagt die nächste uhr
das ist ein fass ohne boden und wenn du
versuchst das fasse auszuschöpfen
es geht immer weiter es gibt immer ein
krasses auto immer ne geile uhr größere
wohnung so und das schon und im
verhältnis dazu was es einen dann zurück
gibt wie
auch immer weniger oder ist zumindest
das was ich jetzt schon so merkel ich
bin ein ökonom und ganz quasi ein
wirtschaftsstudium und ganz beliebt
begriff des abnehmenden grenznutzen und
also wende durst das erste glas wasser
das gibt ja noch richtig im kick das
zehnte glas was allerdings hier was soll
der scheiß sodass der abnehmende nutzen
mit weitere pro weitere einheit ja
schreibt mir jetzt gerne mal eure
meinung in die kommentare rheingold
schon dass man sich nicht als floskel
weil ich in diesem video ist ja wirklich
über themen reden die ich auch spannend
finde die nah an meinem herzen sind
schreibt und schreibt auf was sie von
diesen kleinen talk auskopplung hier so
haltet die nächste kommt dann in zwei
tagen am sonntag gibt es neuen auto test
mit wem sage ich noch nicht aber ja